vamos a hacer otras transformadas de la
plaza que siempre es bueno ver de dónde
vienen todas las transformadas que vemos
en aquellas tablas de transformadas de
la plaza y también para familiarizarnos
con las matemáticas esto normalmente se
ve en las clases de cálculo de segundo
semestre y vamos a comenzar volviendo a
escribir la definición de la
transformada de la plaza l manuscrita se
abre llave escribimos la función en el
dominio de t y esto va a ser igual a la
integral impropia de 0 a infinito
d
a la menos ese porte multiplicada por la
función del té que está dentro de
nuestros coches de la transformada de té
ahora vamos a hacer otra transformada de
la plaza vamos a hacer la transformada
de la plaza y ahora a nuestra función
efe dt va a ser el elevado a a porte
cerramos nuestro corchete
vamos entonces a sustituir esta ft
dentro de la definición de la
transformada así que es la integral
impropia que esto bueno también es una
muy buena práctica para hacer las
integrales ya que las transformadas de
laplace casi siempre terminan siendo
problemas de integración por partes que
es algo que aprendimos a hacer en vídeos
anteriores bueno de todas maneras esto
es igual a la integral impropia de 0 a
infinito
al menos ese porte x
a la corte que esa es nuestra función ft
dt y esto va a ser igual a vamos a
superar los exponentes ya que tenemos la
misma base a la integral de 0 a infinito
de ala vamos escribir
a la a menos s todo esto multiplicado
por t de t
y cuál es dante y derivada de esto
bueno esto va a ser igual
vamos a ver que esto es igual a 1 entre
la parte constante que es a menos s
todo esto va a multiplicar
elevado a la
al menos ese porte todo esto va a estar
evaluado entre cuando se aproxima al
infinito y cuando te es igual a cero
este elemento de aquí es una constante
esto va a ser igual a 1 / a menos s x
vamos a ver cuál es el límite cuando t
se aproxima al infinito qué pasa con
este término tenemos dos casos aquí si
este exponente
este a menos ese es un número positivo a
menos ese es mayor que 0
entonces conforme éste se aproxima al
infinito toda esta parte se va a ser muy
muy muy grande
le vamos a tener un exponente que tiende
al infinito no vamos a tener una
respuesta cuando tenemos las integrales
impropias y se tiende al infinito y en
ese momento no tenemos una respuesta a
un número concreto eso significa que el
límite o la integral impropia no tiene
un límite diverge así que por lo tanto
no va a haber un límite aquí escribimos
no tiene límite por lo tanto la
transformada de la plaza en este caso no
está definida oa es mayor que s no está
definido y qué pasa cuando a es menor
que s
o cuando a menos ese es menor que cero
vamos a tener la elevada a un número
negativo infinitamente el grande y esto
si se aproxima algo se aproxima a cero y
de hecho esto lo vimos en el vídeo
anterior así que bueno espero que
ustedes entiendan lo que estoy
explicando aquí cuando se aproxima a
cero es cuando vamos a tener esta
posibilidad de tener un exponente
negativo entonces vamos a tener cuando
es menor que ese la única opción en la
que nos está va a dar un exponente
negativo y está integral impropia va a
atender a un valor o va a converger en
un valor entonces cuando a menos ese es
menor que cero y tiende al infinito
vamos a tener que todo esto es un cero y
a esto le vamos a restar esta integral
evaluada cuando t es igual a cero cuando
t es igual a cero que pasa bueno esto se
multiplica por cero por lo que cualquier
cosa elevada a la cero va a ser igual a
la transformada o el resultado de todo
esto va a ser igual a menos 1 / a menos
s y es lo mismo que decir 1 entre s
menos a por lo que ya tenemos nuestra
siguiente entrada en nuestra tabla de
transformadas de la plaza aquí la vamos
a escribir nuestra transformada de la
plaza
elevado a la corte va a ser igual a 1
entre s menos
siempre y cuando el valor de s sea mayor
que el de a esto se cumple cuando s es
mayor que a o cuando a es menor que s
cualquiera de las dos es lo mismo así
pues esta es nuestra segunda entrada en
nuestra tabla de transformadas de la
plaza genial bueno de hecho vamos a
relacionar esto con la transformada que
hicimos en el vídeo anterior la cual era
la transformada de la plaza de uno que
es igual a uno entre ese cierto y yo les
pregunto que acaso uno no es lo mismo
que elevada a la cero pues sí es lo
mismo y de hecho puedo escribir aquí
aunque me estoy quedando sin espacio que
es lo mismo que la transformada de la
plaza a la 0 por t lo cual es igual a 1
en 13 y afortunadamente vemos que esto
es consistente con nuestro resultado y
esto de hecho en el anterior tenemos que
ver que esta s es mayor que 0 y es
consistente con el resultado que
acabamos de tener cuando
es mayor que 0 porque en nuestro
resultado actual si a fuera igual a cero
entonces esto quedaría como el resultado
1 entre s ya que la base y 0 de nuevo
asumiendo que s es mayor que 0 así que
podemos decir que todas estas son
variaciones de la misma entrada en
nuestra tabla de transformadas de
laplace y en matemáticas siempre es muy
agradable encontrar que los resultados
obtenidos por los problemas un poco
distintos son congruentes entre sí
esto sería todo por hoy vamos a seguir
construyendo nuestra tabla de
transformadas de la plaza en los
siguientes vídeos y después veremos cómo
todas estas transformadas de la plaza
son extremadamente útiles para resolver
toda una gama de ecuaciones
diferenciales